The Singularity is a hypothetical Future
Point in which technological progress
and artificial intelligence will advance
to the point where Humanity will undergo
a transformation Beyond which it cannot
be seen it will be such a profound
transformation that predicting beyond
that is kind of trivial or meaningless
many people postulate that that's the
point where it will become either
self-aware and it will start to make its
own decisions and ignore us it's the
classic well what if it wants to kill us
well it won't really want to kill us
because it has no reason to do for the
same reason that we don't want to kill
ants but if we build a highway we
destroy some ant hills so it's just
gonna do what it's gonna do this is why
Elon and Sam Altman and those guys are
trying to align our goals of humanity
with the goals of the AI it's the only
really productive thought process we can
have because we can sit here and be
afraid but I don't think we're going to
stop the technological progress